hey 42 here humankind loves to look up
towards new challenges and greater
aspirations whether we're building
immense skyscrapers climbing the tallest
mountains or reaching for the stars we
never stop striving to better ourselves
but our world has plenty more to explore
and discover even if it means reaching a
little lower perhaps a lot lower deep
beneath the sea and buried far
underground and even at the very center
of the earth let's take a look at seven
of the deepest places in the world far
beneath the chill waters of the western
Pacific Ocean the Marianas Trench
stretches across the seafloor in a realm
that light has never touched the deepest
point appropriately called challenger
deep has been measured at ten thousand
nine hundred and ninety four kilometers
below sea level give or take 40 meters
the bottom of the trench was seen for
the very first time on January the 23rd
1960 by oceanographer Jack's Picard
along with u.s. Navy lieutenant Don
Walsh from within a cramped bathyscaphe
they missed a challenger deep by a few
meters but they were still able to
observe the floor of the Marianas Trench
which was noted to be quote-unquote
light and clear a waste of snuff
coloured news despite the crushing
weight of the water above the intrepid
explorers were certainly shocked to find
life waiting for them at the very bottom
in the form of some type of flatfish
resembling a soul about one foot and six
inches across
if sixteen thousand pounds of pressure
per square inch can't dissuade life from
finding away perhaps there's a lesson to
be learned there later expeditions
revealed other extreme forms of life
like giant amoebas measuring 10
centimeters in diameter now before the
nightmare set in it might be worth
noting that the amoebas didn't exactly
resemble a single-celled organisms as we
think of them but more like a sea sponge
or a coral scientists dubbed these
creatures Zeno fire force which is
science peak for they look like aliens
the IVA of Discovery continues even to
this day
Hollywood director and science both
James Cameron performed the deepest solo
sub dive into the Marianas Trench on
March the 25th 2012 using his
custom-built submersible he collected
samples of the EZ sediments and even
captured 3d video of the entire dive
hoping to gain a better understanding of
the ocean's depth and spur support for
future expeditions there's certainly a
lot left for us to discover down there
as long as we don't anger Cthulhu we
should be okay just a short distance
southwest of Johannesburg in South
Africa lies perhaps the greatest
achievement in the world of mining since
the invention of the simple pickaxe
miners in the impending gold mine have
been hard at work since 1981 sifting the
earth to produce gold from a vein that
averages less than a meter wide an
interesting dichotomy when you consider
that the mp9 gold mine is the deepest
mined in the world and it's all thanks
to that relatively tiny golden thread
most of the work is done between two
point four and 3.9 kilometers deep the
latter number being the current world
record for mining depth and the digging
continues extracting 5400 metric tons of
rock daily expansion efforts seek to
ensure the mines long-term viability
purely a precautionary measure as in
2012 alone the mine produced around
11,500 kilograms of gold that's 460
million dollars of the golden good stuff
if you're still undecided on a career
path perhaps you might want to consider
becoming a miner but it's not all fun
and games that far down into the Earth's
crust the closer you get to the core of
our planet
the hotter things get in turn this is
unaffected geothermal gradient and it's
a constant concern for the intrepid - of
the mp9 gold mine if you were to descend
with the deepest point in the mine the
temperature of the surrounding strata
would reach temperatures of up to 60
degrees Celsius consider the harsh on
yielding stone surrounding you and
you've got the makings of an oven
inhospitable working conditions for sure
but thanks to a constant stream of
slurry ice
through the mine the temperature is
maintained it's a far more bearable 30
degrees Celsius still a sweltering day
in the mines but hey at least you won't
end up Broyles caves have long held a
special sort of a law for explorers
natural fissures in the terrain which
offer nooks and crannies for those brave
enough to test their shadowy depths
krubera cave located in a particularly
porous area of western Russia known as
the Arabica massive isn't just any old
cave it bears the unique distinction of
being the deepest cave in the world it
is with no small measure of respect that
some cavers have taken to calling it the
Everest of caves evoking images of the
danger and excitement that many find in
summiting tallest mountains krubera cave
was recognized for its record depth in
August of 2004 after a particularly
stoic band of cave explorers followed
its twisting path downward to a total
depth of 2080 meters it's the only
natural formation known to humankind
greater than two kilometers deep and it
even has a reserve of water at the very
bottom known as the terminal Sun that's
as far as a team of cavers could go with
the equipment that they had with them in
2007 and the gain in 2012 a ukrainian
diver by the name of gennady samokhin
climbed down to the sump with all the
necessary equipment to plunge into the
icy water and map the tail end of the
cave he earned world records with both
dives and added another 98 metres to the
total depth in the process so if you've
ever fancied a long climb with a brief
swim at the bottom then there's a bloody
scary idea for you to add to your next
vacation once you're through spelunking
in krubera cave head east into siberia
to find the next stop on our whirlwind
tour of the world's deepest places lake
baikal the depth isn't the only
interesting thing about this
crescent-shaped reservoir cutting
through the Russian mainland though it
is both the deepest freshwater lake and
the deepest continental body of water to
be found on our planet
besides reaching incredible depths
there's plenty of other facts about the
lake to get excited about
especially if you're a scientist
geologically Lake Baikal is the oldest
freshwater lake in the world and it
contains nearly 20% of the world's
unfrozen freshwater reserve not to say
that it doesn't freeze over from time to
time it is Siberia after all the lake
and its surrounds are also home to an
incredibly diverse collection of flora
and fauna with some estimates
identifying around one thousand three
hundred and forty different species of
animals living harmoniously we've
operated five hundred and seventy
species of plants a lost fry and
ecosystem to be cataloged in and around
an ancient lake of remarkable depth and
those eager scientists might even be
able to make it home for dinner we're
going to have to bend the rules a bit
for this next one though the Bentley
subglacial trench in Western Antarctica
isn't technically covered in water it is
well covered in water but not the wet
kind the trench is actually the lowest
point on the earth not covered by an
ocean or other form of flowing water
sitting at 2.5 kilometres below sea
level as you might expect subglacial
means that it is sequestered beneath the
frozen mass of majestic glacier
surrounded by many of a similar
stretches of ice all across the
Antarctic continent this means that the
Bentley subglacial trench is actually
subterranean though it's still a point
on the Earth's surface just not one you
could walk to I told you we'd have to
cheat a bit it was named by the Advisory
Committee on Antarctic names in 1961 in
arnhem of Charles R Bentley and his
contributions to Antarctic research as
the chief Traverse seismologist a bride
stationed between 1957 and 1959 seeing
as he was the one who led the expedition
which first located a trench and
recorded its depth it seems an
appropriate legacy for him to leave
behind in the snowy wastes who knows the
copier secluded spot in Antarctica just
waiting for you to slap your name all
over it as well when in doubt start
drilling straight down and don't stop
until the earth itself rejects you
not exactly sensible advice but someone
involved with the Kola super-deep
borehole project
must have heard it somewhere and really
took it to heart during the Cold War
there was a constant back-and-forth
between United States and the Soviet
Union each seeking to one-up each other
on the global stage scientific endeavors
flee fast and furious one of the results
being the Soviets decision to set a
drill into the ground of the Kola
Peninsula and dig as deep as possible
there were certainly valid scientific
reasons for the project but it almost
sound as if they were just waiting for
an excuse to do it
the drilling began in 1970 and it didn't
stop until 1994 producing what we call
today the Kola super-deep borehole the
deepest hole ever drilled to date under
the deepest artificial point in the
world reaching a mind-boggling 12
kilometers into the crust of our planet
that's deeper than even the Challenger
Deep in the end the borehole encountered
the same issue as the miners in the mp9
gold mine things get really hot that
deep underground temperatures at the end
of the shaft climbed to around 180
degrees Celsius no not Fahrenheit but
Celsius that's a brain melting 356
Fahrenheit the equipment simply couldn't
continue to function in those conditions
and so the Kola super-deep borehole had
reached its end but rumors continue to
swirl around about what exactly brought
about the conclusion of the drilling
there are come fire ghost stories about
microphones that were lowered into the
shaft which recorded the sound of
tortured screams what's really going on
at the center of the earth well let me
tell you at the very center of our
planet lies a sphere of solid iron at
least as best as we can tell with
current data deeper than the molten
mantle and liquid metal outer core the
inner core seems to be formed of a
massive non-uniform ball of iron it is
this core and the extreme heat as a
result of several factors working in
tandem that serves to heat the planet
from within the same heat which Ward's
off any attempt to burrow through the
crust it's as if the underworld as
feverishly trying to keep us at bay
there must be something going on down
there the estimated temperature the
boundary between the molten metal of the
outer core and the solid inner core is
around 5,600 degrees Kelvin
to put that into some perspective the
temperature of our Sun surface is 5,800
degrees Kelvin only 200 more some
predict that the Earth's core might even
be hotter than the surface of the Sun
thanks to pressure friction and
radioactive elements the earth
essentially has a miniature Sun burning
at its very heart perhaps we will never
get to see the very core of the earth
with our own eyes but we can dream and
every crevice borehole and trench that
we discover can bring us that much
closer to understanding the unsearchable
depth beneath us and no matter how deep
we go it can only get warmer and
brighter
once the darkest places are behind us
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you